شريان الحياة الذي يحافظ على بعض الروابط
بين العائلات الممزقة يتم إرساله
في ملاحظات صوتية إلى مذيع الراديو ماد
[موسيقى]
أبو راديو AAL خصص خطوطه الجوية
لسنوات لعائلات
الآلاف من الفلسطينيين الذين
يحاولون يائسين الوصول إلى أحبائهم
المحتجزين في
السجون الإسرائيلية، عمة المستمع الشاب،
ناشطة فلسطينية، اعتقلت
السلطات الإسرائيلية مع آلاف
الفلسطينيين الآخرين بعد
الهجوم الدامي الذي نفذته حماس في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول. تحاول المحطة
دعم العائلات التي
تنتظر بشدة أي أخبار من
داخل السجون الإسرائيلية
في أعقاب الهجوم المروع.
هجوم حماس لم تنفذ إسرائيل
عمليات اعتقال جماعية للفلسطينيين فحسب، بل
حرمت السجناء من جميع الاتصالات العائلية.
هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكن لعائلاتهم من خلالها
توصيل الكم الهائل من الرسائل التي
تثبت واقع
السجن هنا. يسمح القانون الإسرائيلي
باحتجاز السجناء الفلسطينيين إلى
أجل غير مسمى دون  المحاكمة أو
التهمة المعلنة، لا تعرف العائلات حتى
ما إذا كان السجناء سيستمعون إلى
رسائلهم، لكن هذا لا يمنعهم من
إرسال
مستنقع الرهائن إلى إسرائيل وحماس، حيث يتم
تبادل 150 سجينًا فلسطينيًا محتجزًا لدى إسرائيل من
النساء والمراهقات مقابل 50
رهينة محتجزة لدى حماس، مما يعني ذلك  في الوقت الحالي،
هناك بعض المساعدة لكل من
العائلات الإسرائيلية والفلسطينية، سنلتقي
بسيدة فلسطينية يعود أحد
أحبائها إلى المنزل ولكن دائمًا في
هذا السياق وفي هذه الحالة،
لا توجد عائلات بهذه البساطة على كلا الجانبين
حتى أولئك الذين  ينتظرون عودة
من يحبون ويتعاملون أيضًا مع
واقع أولئك الذين لن يعودوا إلى
المنزل، تم القبض على حنان زوجة شقيق إيمان البطي
مع أبنائها الثلاثة، ولا
يزال الأبناء في السجن حنان على
القائمة القادمة
قالت إيمان في المنزل إنها لا هي ولا حنان
منخرطتان في سياسة هذه الحرب ومع ذلك
فهما يعانيان من عواقبها الآن. لقد
تزوجا أم أبنائها ولديهم
أطفال ينتظرون رؤية
جدتهم، كما تعلم أن لديها
علاقة جميلة معهم.  إنها تحب
الجميع وسط فرحة إيمان
بحنان، وبدأت تأمل في أن يتم
إطلاق سراح زوجها NTI، وهو أسير سياسي فلسطيني أمضى أطول فترة في عملية مبادلة، إنه
يوم سعيد بالنسبة لنا، ونحن نعلم أن هذا
سيبدأ لأنه  وهذا يعني أن
زوجي سيأتي زوجي الذي يقبع في
السجن الآن منذ 44 عامًا عندما تم
اعتقاله، وكان ذلك في المرة الأولى في عام
1978. تحظى عائلة الباروتي باحترام
العديد من الفلسطينيين الذين يعتبرونهم تهديدًا من قبل
دولة إسرائيل ذا قيمة كافية لحماس.  تم
تضمينهم في
صفقة حماس الإسرائيلية لعام 2011 بين
1100 فلسطيني مقابل جندي إسرائيلي واحد
جلاد شاليط بعد أن احتجزت حماس
شاليط لمدة 5 سنوات والذي تم تبادله
في ذلك اليوم، الرجل الذي تقول إسرائيل إنه
مهندس هجوم 7 أكتوبر الذي
شنته حماس.  حقيقة
تطارد كل خطوة تقوم بها إسرائيل أثناء
تفاوضها من أجل إطلاق سراح المزيد من
الرهائن المحتجزين لدى حماس بينما تنتظر العائلات على كلا
الجانبين وتنتظر
الأمل.